thank you very much the members of the
academy for this and I uh the other
nominees some of them are very good
friends of mine and I'm I'm honored to
be on any list with you Bobby Dusty and
you and your father Mr James
my old bike pal Fonda we're very proud
of the picture we had like uh I don't
know I've had a sinking feeling all
night right up till here something about
it I'd like to thank I'd like to thank
everybody here tonight for looking so
good
I'd like to dedicate this to Miles Davis
Robert Mitchum shorty Smith Joe vitrano
Ray Kramer Rupert cross
JT Walsh and Luana Anders they're not
here anymore but they're in my heart and
I thank you very much
[Applause]